just real quick an observation of the
haircut and myself it makes my ears look
smaller I think I don't think I've ever
noticed your ears hey it's a regular
shape - how big they are you guys gonna
squeeze it a little bit okay
I think I'm that yep no hi my name is
grace Helbig no no you know your life is
different now I'm here with Hannah Hart
mamrie Hart and we after Lily I'm very
excited because I thought a year and a
half ago we shot a video for MAME race
last book in which we don't into
memories fashion you did we took a trip
down memory lane I think I forget it no
brakes and I like to read chicken
infomercials Rumble boom [ __ ] rest in
peace in peace you look so good in this
day that there is no sag in those SAG
Awards hey yo know what's next you build
me up I think today because it has a new
holiday book and it's only appropriate
that we do our due diligence for Hannah
Hart and take a trip down memory lane
and look at some of Hannah Hart's best
loops that she served over the last
maybe decade when she had bigger ears
I'm sweating okay I wasn't in on this
fYI what's the game don't let's dive in
these are in no real particular order
finish our number at 1 through 13 guys
just so you know if I tear up during
this it's because I think I bought a
jalapeno in my eyes it's very warm I'm
sweating first look oh you did have such
a big a backwards hat with the best face
and rolled t-shirt sleeve this is also
taken this era yeah I like to call
Topshop comes to America I call this
looks preteen crime solver oh yeah a kid
who's like man I gotta go get some facts
but it's all adult
Hannah Hart I think the first streamys
that we all ever went to I hate I
remember you showing us what you were
going to wear and being like isn't as
cool but I'm going to leave it untied
and I'm gonna let it hang and we were
both like yeah meanwhile I'm still
figuring out I just cut my own bags but
if you did a revamped version of this
with like a playful under thing like
it's not a bad concept I just wasn't
executed correct yeah cuz you look like
you went to make a business deal but
you've got like freshly [ __ ] in the
custody hearing first time I told you I
loved you was on a stage at this dreamy
yeah it was a very wonderful night for
all of us oh yeah work shows have
evolved I know with that asset and with
their logo being tails you look like
you're at like not dolphin trainers
award they're telling the Dolphins like
let's go back in time a little bit I
just wanna hit this arrow one more the
floral and the floral sneakers and the
classic hand a hand when you decided
that this is your red carpet pose there
are spiders me too I was kidding
she's terrible arch support Wow our
names upgraded version of the best and
this is incredible thank you for you
save some money I did you know it turns
out you could save a lot of money way
you don't wear a shirt they don't wake
somebody hey you got a little peekaboo
mom a little bit of your tattoo oh no I
just might keep some guessing okay yeah
it feels like you really like this is a
true evolution from the best like you're
still I could invest money in some sort
of stocks but like you can get freshly
should look like this afterwards I love
so much how so many my photos are all
about me being freshly shot
we always have that expression on your I
didn't even realize it seemed like you
and the group photos I didn't see your
full look it's amazing and I call this
outfit hair sighs oh I had to pee so bad
on the red carpet that if you go and get
all these photos you got a light pole
protruding glass I think you could call
this smart and smarter because you're
like an elevated cool sister of dumb and
dumber
ah there you go I feel like this reminds
me of like sexy Nickelodeon would you
say this Nickelodeon has been fresh this
is like Nickelodeon that's been freshly
there we go I'm one red carpet to a
purple carpet yeah hey Hanna surprised
us by wearing a dress to the dirty
thirty premiere I can tell you guys
right you didn't tell us and we told you
we were getting spray tan I will take
one of my favorite pictures and captions
of the three of us yeah the flight
attendants
because you guys look so good and I'm
just like coffee also like there's
something about wearing a dress that I
find very inhibiting it makes you feel
very vulnerable exactly okay now checked
off your bucket list
jitka oh my god an important look that I
think should be recognized I mean this
is the one at home casual I'm cooking in
my kitchen yeah I want to make sure that
you represented all ends of the spectrum
in terms of people are like what's going
on with your glasses
she fresh it's a bowl of kick batter
this is a mukbang I love how you charge
people money for posters they know how
often Ella tries to get me to do a sexy
calendar I'm not talking about sexy I'm
talking about this photo all right Oh
cute your hair oh is this a bad memory
no no I just hate this thanks guys you
know that you might have stomachache
I guess I just find this photo very
confusing but is this photo about what
story this is tell hopefully this one
yeah the story okay go through the
motions as a dinner party tonight again
but back to my sweat yeah I made gnocchi
this is a great combination of you
looking like business casual but also
like stepping out of your comfort zone a
little you're in a mesh top I love that
I think art is your color
yeah it's yeah yeah the peekaboo of the
tattoo yeah your jewelry agrees you're
gonna lose your tattoo girl yeah video
goes to the beach the day that you got
engaged divine thought for a fraction of
a second but this would end up as a
people exclusive
oh here's the most amazing discovery
that I had today that I cannot wait to
share with you I got nervous excited so
just take a look at the shirt and then
let me show you
patterns million subscribers I am really
so she came over and we were like might
we're not getting out we're doing a live
stream until you hit a million she made
a bet with everyone online that was you
you put a dress on in memory game I just
had that beautiful dress my remember I
had a huge floral 60s dress yeah I'm a
brace at the moment that really will
tattoo Allah made it edgy I don't think
this really allows you to blossom into
the fashion icon that you are today
throughout the years and you know new
haircut
yeah let us know wanna think so I feel
like there's a new era on the variety
and yeah honey let's do your 2020 look
your North always congested okay
no not that okay okay so got tired I got
time and you know that you only decide
on your yearly fashion by like literally
the last show my 2019 this trip down
memory lane I spent a lot of fun and I
am so glad you guys were there to
witness every step of the way every step
and repeat of the way and memory show
notes as we made videos over there and
if you like this to be still tall people
I give thumbs up yeah if you haven't
Instagram yeah alright
other than that I don't know wait no hi
Hannah pics